dr weill bonsoir oui on vous invite à
des moments charnières parce que là
monsieur legault dit après noël on peut
songer si les enfants se font bien
vaccinés comme prévu on peut songer à
laisser tomber unes après les autres les
mesures distanciation masques etc est ce
que vous êtes 2 7s que j'arrivais à la
même conclusion dans vos analyses
moi je pense qu'il ya des mesures qui
laissera jamais tomber jusqu'à un
certain point par exemple dans les
hôpitaux le fait de porter un masque
continuellement un impact majeur sur la
transmission de beaucoup de virus qui ne
sont pas là qu'ovide néocons patients
aux personnels et c'est donc des
avantages à garder certaines mesures
d'un milieu de la santé le mois de
janvier faut pas oublier puis là c'est
la pleine période de la saison
respiratoires ce qu'on sait de
l'hémisphère sud c'est qu'on risque
d'avoir une petite année d'influenza
mais on sait jamais par contre on a
beaucoup de virus qu'on appelle du virus
respiratoire syncytial autre chose que
ça nous dit ça nous dit qu'on est prêt
maintenant à accepter à vivre non plus
avec une pandémie mais avec une endémie
c'est à dire avec un virus qui reste là
de façon persistante un bas bruit
parfois qui va augmenter en termes de
nombre on va avoir des éclosions ici et
là et que donc il va falloir composer
avec une vie normale mais en acceptant
continuellement d'avoir un certain
nombre de cas d'avoir un certain nombre
de patients hospitalisés et dépendamment
de la situation dans la grée tôt quand
pour la grippe de fermer ou d'ouvrir les
vannes donc la loi des mesures d'urgence
et un contexte les gaz c'est pas un
contexte de science donc oui ça peut
avoir des implications et je ne suis
certainement pas juriste pour discuter
des implications de l'aspect les gars de
cette fois de là mais la science en tant
que tel de dire que par exemple à
l'intérieur des des transports en commun
en plein hiver si les gens sont habitués
à porter des masques ça peut avoir un
effet bénéfique
comme on le voit dans beaucoup de pays
asiatiques de garder l'aspect du la rage
est mince et très bien le lavage des
mains ou un autre il faut qu'on va
hériter des mesures de l'accord ide qui
vont persister qui vont rester mais pour
le bien de beaucoup d'autres choses
qui seront peut-être plus à la cohue
donc ces deux choses à mon sens qu'ils
sont séparés on verra vous êtes
inévitablement plus de masques dans nos
vies au cours des prochaines années
qu'on en voyait ici mais la question
c'est est ce que ça sera obligatoire par
exemple pour entrer dans un magasin est
ce qu'on va pas en janvier février mars
à arriver un moment où ça ne sera plus
obligatoire
ça va être une décision qui va être une
décision politique puis on verra à ce
moment là la situation épidémiologique
de la copie d'opter bêtes et on verra
aussi la situation épidémiologique des
autres virus parce que faut pas oublier
que l'an dernier on a eu une année avec
zéro je tiens zéro cas de finances a
donc de grippe parce que bien sûr la
corrida pris toute la place mais parce
qu'aussi on a pris toutes sortes de
mesures en place m'ont fait il n'y a pas
une transmission cette année il ya le
retour à l'école on a ouvert la société
ce qui est très très bien mais dans ce
contexte là on veut pas non plus avoir
des infections dit nosocomiales on va
avoir de transmission des noms connus
que l'alliance à la principale
conséquence est une conséquence
économique c'est-à-dire que quand vous
avez beaucoup de grip dans une société
les enfants tombola repas à l'école les
parents restent à la maison pour
s'occuper des enfants ne vont pas
travailler donc il ya des conséquences
économiques à ça et dans le cinéma ça
peut permettre de contrôler ce genre de
choses là pourquoi pas comme outil de
contrôle et non pas comme outil
législatif au ou quoi que ce soit du
genre oui dans certains contextes mais
dr weiss vous il ya fort longtemps ça
nous pareil au milan mais vous m'aviez
dit ça va prendre deux ans à peu près
d'ailleurs vous étiez pas mal
clairvoyant parce qu'on on est rendu là
vingt mois plus tard
il faudra vivre avec le risque est le
risque zéro n'existe pas dans pour aller
je ne sais pas nous au bureau par
exemple si on a le masque dès que je
sors du plateau et c est ce que vous
voyez quand même un retour à une
certaine normalité
pour pour ce symbole qui est devenu oui
dans les hôpitaux oui dans les
transports en commun en jeu blanc
atteint mais par ailleurs on pourra
libérer un peu non oui tout à fait mais
y aura une condition si c'est d'essayer
de racine et rapidement la population à
risque parce que supposons qu au mois de
janvier on dise que la situation est
tellement bonne au québec et qu'on
allait les masses par exemple dans les
sandales ou dans les endroits intérieure
publique où il ya beaucoup de monde et
là vous allez avoir des gens de la
population disons de plus de 65 ans qui
aurait été vaccinées il ya plus de six
mois qui deviendrait un peu plus
vulnérables à rattraper lakovic
peut-être pas très malade peut-être ils
n'iront pas à l'hôpital mais risquant
même d'être positive de temps en temps
donc de ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que un moment donné il faut avoir aussi
une stratégie qui est souvent une
stratégie multiples allers on l'a dit
c'est un agrégat de mesures en anglais
on appelle ça un bandeau qui nous permet
de contrôler la copie c'est la
vaccination en premier lieu le masque le
lavage des mains la distanciation donc
c'est un ensemble de facteurs
ça a eu un impact positif sur les autres
virus respiratoires et oui on est déjà
revenu en face à la pression que j'ai
docteur va j'ai l'impression que vous
êtes médecin c'est normal comme ça eu
des effets positifs sur les autres virus
et tout ça vous vous dites comme médecin
bon ben continuons comme ça mais en même
temps il ya d'autres aspects qui sont
pas idéales de porter le masque dans
plusieurs circonstances oui tout à fait
et puis je veux pas du tout envoyer le
message qu'on va devenir une société à
masquer et un peu renfermé pas du tout
au contraire
moi ce que je dis c'est qu'on est
retourné déjà une société beaucoup plus
améliorée aujourd'hui que ce qu'on était
il ya six mois et encore bien mieux que
ce qu'on était il ya un an on est revenu
au québec avec une société pas mal ou
vert pour y retourner à l'école aux
universités les gens sont tournés
travailler et caetera et donc et
j'espère qu'on sera capable d'enlever
quasiment toutes les mesures à un moment
donné rémy va rester une certaine
endémicité de ce virus là qui va faire
que on va devoir vivre avec gérer le
virus et dans certains environnements
entre autres de milieu hospitalier le
milieu de la santé les freins des chs il
va falloir orlando dr vince eddie's
enfin pour expliquez moi pourquoi pas ce
cas on sent beaucoup de crainte chez les
parents autant les parents qui eux mêmes
sont allés se faire vacciner se disent à
ma petite de 7 ans le petit bros qu
est-ce que pourquoi les enfants c'est
important de les vacciner les 50 ans
d'après vous bien souvent c'est la
catégorie actuellement qui transmet
entre si vous voulez
beaucoup de cas proportionnellement ce
qui représente dans la population c'est
tout à fait normal donc si on veut
retourner à une vie encore plus normal
c'est un autre bassin de la population
qu'il faut toucher en termes de
vaccination pour réduire l'impact du
virus sur la population québécoise en
général les enfants je me donne un
exemple imaginez que vous ne va signer
par les enfants et que vous êtes un
travailleur de la santé où quelqu'un qui
travaille qui est doublement vacciner et
que vous avez un enfant quitte est
positif anatolie quand vous test vous
testé positif vous n'êtes pas très
malade c'est même plus une question que
vous soyez très malade mais là qu'est ce
qu'on fait ce qu'on voulait se retourner
travailler est ce qu'on vous dit
d'attendre quelques jours à la maison
donc ça aura des impacts économiques ça
aura toutes sortes
de tontons d'autres façons donc c'est
encore là un outil supplémentaire pas
absolue il n'y a pas de cet avis vous
êtes à l'aise avec cela vous si vous
aviez déjà
oui tout à fait vous savez mes enfants
ont été vaccinés dès qu'elles ont pu
être vaccinés dont ça a été très rapide
très bien
dr vince est toujours un plaisir de vous
parler merci beaucoup à très bientôt au
revoir à voir